to give the award for Best Director
we've been entirely logical and invited
the gentleman who is himself the best
director last year he received the Oscar
for Gandhi actually he's more than a
gentleman he's a knight of the realm to
his friends and to the colleagues with
whom he works he's known as Dicky
tonight I choose to be more formal
ladies and gentlemen Sir Richard
Attenborough
express thanks for the joyous relief
that I feel appearing here this evening
as against last year when my stomach
felt it was on a permanent roller
coaster I would also like to express
thanks for the honor that the Academy do
me and allowing me to remain we read the
names of my very distinguished
colleagues the nominations for best
director best achievement in directing
are peter yates
for the dresser
Ingmar Bergman for Fanny and Alexander
Mike Nichols for Silkwood
Bruce Beresford for tender mercies
and James L Brooks for terms of
endearment
the winner is James L Brooks returns of
Indiana
I feel like I've been beaten up its
range this was uh in in the truest sense
of the word enormous Lee collaborative
film Andre Park Kovacs talent is on
every frame Richard Marx was a dream in
a cutting room friend of mine named Dave
Davis worked with me from beginning to
end
Polly Platt was in an extraordinary
contribution Chris Diaz costumes meant a
lot because to the picture I think the
picture depended so much on detail and
and I'm overwhelmed I'm very grateful
Olli you're great okay thank you very
much